m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j
j'ai maintenant 120 au parlement
le chômage
[Musique]
je suis pas
je
[Musique]
un autre
toujours ma tête ma parole vous gagner
en trichant rendez-vous les mange notre
pain ici merde c'est pas vraiment pas
comment géopolitique je suis d'accord
avec toi mais pas été pour l'instant
gonna work with human rights mais je lui
donne raison
vous êtes un habitué de la goutte d'or
oui et non les jours de semaine ravages
en général j'aime bien que les samedis
les dimanches
j'habite le troisième enfin je connais
personne à parlement compléter notre
bouche et c'est pour ça que je ne viens
que les 110 le dimanche et vous venez
ici pour rencontrer des gens du quartier
non oui mais la plupart des gens qui
viennent un petit peu de partout vient
de la banlieue enfin de la légion
parisien un ancien pauvre commission est
aussi des ingénieurs des consignes city
viennent pour des vacances et puis il ya
aussi des compatriotes qu'ils ont des
postes à des problèmes de boulot froid
ben moi en tant qu'électricien j'essaie
dans la mesure du possible d'essayer de
faire quelque chose pourrait enfin de
les embaucher avec moi ou ou l'allemand
triste début lointier mari puisse avoir
un boulot tu es quand on se retrouve
dans un café comme ici parle de quoi
roucourt bon ça commence par des blagues
à ce refus schoettel qui peut on se
chamaille se raconte des histoires enfin
pas de blague un truc
et puis on évoque un petit peu les les
anciens souvenez
paul du pays et des fois relaté ici
c'est un hollandais comme moi je viens
dans le domaine des nouvelles du pays
comment que ça va ça va si ça ne va pas
s'il a vu nos parents ce qu'ils en
pensent vous savez les parents
s'inquiètent beaucoup sur le sujet se
suivent à savoir si on est bien je te
dis si on travaille ainsi on a une bonne
situation si on est dans le droit chemin
plus ça parce qu'ils s'inquiètent
beaucoup parce qu'on ne sont pas tous
les ans
tous les deux en phase aller jusqu'à
trois ans ou plus et puis on évoque un
petit peu cela l'évolution
enfin dispute temps de l' ocde de
l'ouest mais tu est encadré par du bal
de l'est et puis on le savait c'est à
dire la été bons malgré tout le temps
parle de bazooka démentir thatcher puis
on évoque aussi un petit peu
l'indépendance dépendance
les bijoux qu'on a passé cette année de
joie enfin de kelly attaqué l'annoncé du
jour on n'a pas ça mais on n'a pas mangé
on n'a pas dû on a vu que ont l'âme et
puis on ne mangeait que nos joies et
vous aimez ce quartier ben oui ce sont
plus cons chez nous las malgré qu'ils
allaient flics et puis les crs qui z'ont
qu'à tout le quartier
on dépense pose la question qui nous
place des sauvages pour des cannibales
et puis ça s'arrête là
ça vous arrive de sortir ailleurs dans
paris 3 en pensez voici un bon match de
foot enfin signer pro c'est d'aller
manger une pizza
et puis on essaye investisseurs un petit
peu dans des boîtes et puis il faut
arriver dans une boîte c'est complet
merci de ne pas insister et puis allaoua
les gens qui rentrent et qui sans lui
non c'est que des fois ça m'allait le
jeu me plaît à brooke sheen quoi d'avoir
déchiré pour vous là ça me pose pas de
problèmes je suis là je lance ce qu'on
sent une belle musique impe les manger
vite une cavalière
je vais ma danse et puis dans la main et
puis là ce avait un petit problème un de
ses amis thirau écouter on vous connaît
[Musique]
des programmes qui support au quinté
deux pros ça finit toujours par un petit
marathon durant une bagarre maroc qui se
passe on essuie des gîtes et stella côté
l'inter et à tous les algériens paris un
salé les hauts placés une belle cheveux
ils sont dix à saké zone du poney ans
les postes permanents
le problème ne se pose que pour vous les
pauvres commencer nous l'ailé vraiment
mais quand dans mon histoire
voici d'autres c'est dans ce quartier
enfin vous allez l'équipe qui s'applique
locale tient mais on les voit pas
souvent on en voit d ailleurs beaucoup
et où l'histoire s'ils descendent les
italiens allemands
enfin à touristes
et puis là il vient uniquement pour les
arabes
[Musique]
si la musique en streaming
je viens
bush
[Musique]
est-ce que tu touches soi même
ouais
oui
bon ou un bon tacle de quoi baisser si
jamais couché
j'aime les uns les autres et ça lâche
beach a dit jamais à chaud sorti en 2004
à 2010 la surmonter les onze mille
francs
quand j'étais chez moi aurons dès les
années 1970
tu voyais pas mal d'immigrés qui
travaillent ici en france et les belles
bagnoles bien bonjour j'ai rencontré un
ami qu'on avait travaillé ensemble puis
je lui avais fait si cet arrêté
dès son but on s'est embrassés j'ai
invité à prendre quelque chose
puis il a commencé à discuter un petit
peu la france puis je lui ai dit qu'il
avait une belle bagnole je conviens
qu'il a payé main répondant de 700 mille
balles
si bien que keegan bien ta ville partie
ouais je vais 400 mille balles par mois
l'attitude à celui d'hier mais en tant
que nous dit qualifie naples et toi
quand même curieux peuvent facilement tu
vraiment les six cent mille balles
pilar n'ai jamais fait un petit calcul
qu'on travaille en trois mois en france
sur les 1 million 200 mille
je voulais acheter une manière là 600 à
700 milles mal comme les puits acheter
un outil à je travaille depuis des
sondes au pays et quand vous êtes arrivé
à paris comment ça s'est passé
ben une fois sur les lieux c'est à dire
à paris je n'ai pas eu le confort comme
ati comme un génie prix puis je n'ai pas
eue c'est à dire
le boulot que je faisais avant puis je
n'ai pas eu les six cent mille balles
comédie enfin je n'ai rien vu j'ai
commencé par salle de la manutention et
puis syndicat des chargées des wagons à
charger des wagons chargés des stades et
des camions aussi comme décharger des
camions fait un petit peu sali le
ramassage pour des divisons c'est à dire
autant des colis pour faire la livraison
et sk n'y ait pas assez je connais 300
francs par semaine et ça adulé pendant
deux ans vous étiez assez isolé s'était
offert par vraiment isolé
j'étais tout seul dans mon coin et puis
y ait de ma vie c'était le boulot boulot
dit que vous aviez 30 mille francs par
semaine ça faisait pas beaucoup ça oui
ça me faisait pas beaucoup
puis je pouvais pas car dix économies
m'est arrivé de rester trois mois pour
m'acheter un vêtement n'est pas ça m'est
arrivé d'être en présence des copains
dans les bars enfin mais pas ma tournée
quoi simplement uniquement pour le
bloquer des stadiers les enfants ou les
parents
je ne pouvais pas
et des fois ma forme téléphonique bas
je le lisais j'étais bien que j'ai déjà
acheté ma voiture
le billet acheté mon maquillage afin
j'ai tout
que je m'apprête à rentrer au pays puis
en terminant ma femme tous deux fois ce
mois déjà dans les rues d'ibb on
n'oublie pas de me demander des rock
band et langue de chez nous et surtout
n'oubliez pas le petit format pour
casser tous ces mensonges
j'avais un petit peu de soucis quoi
je m'achetais c'est à dire les soirs en
temps chez moi je m'abstiens cartonnage
je te dire de bien et puis je monte chez
moi je mettais tout ça c'est
impressionnant tout l'argentin puisse
commencer à écrire des lettres des amis
famille ma femme toute la famille
je les veux un petit peu une fois
terminée mais si bien ben je me mettais
au dos et vous connaissiez la goutte
d'or à l'époque ben non c'est à dire lui
énorme et c'est le jour où notre
compatriote a ouvert ce qu'elle fait là
c'est là que j'ai commencé à venir
toutes les 5 août et samedi et dimanche
passera et c'est là que j'ai rencontré
des potes des compatriotes convaincre
qu'ils a eu les mêmes problèmes que moi
et là on sait changer un petit peu les
idées en un lieu c'est à dire m
comment qu'il faut opérer comment qu'il
faut avoir un bon boulot c'est un truc
et puis c'est là que en face à ça
soulage énormément comparer avec des
compagnies connaissent eux seuls et puis
c'est là que j'ai eu dans ma branche
j'aimerais mais quand ça allait mal vous
n'allez pas penser à rentrer au pays
ben vous savez tous les ont rappelé la
neige me suis dit tiens ça n'a pas été
cette année et l'année prochaine série
allait pas j'ai commencé un seuil et
puis ça a duré pendant trois ans
si pour nous c'est un problème quand on
m'a dit ça va comme ça au pays
et moi qui avais promis à ma femme la
lune la vie des jeunes de les amener des
bijoux les apathiques et cadeaux pour la
famille pour les amis je ne pouvais pas
descendre les mains vides
aux yeux c'est à dire des voisins et des
copains si tu l'as acheté quoi je suis
un lâche je suis un bon à rien je
voulais avoir pour rien s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
ces trois femmes seules 25 56 52 57 3 5
à 9 oui j'ai 3 5 4 68 81 02 38 16 77 10
302 2,55 à 28,80 de 17 ses 300 330 84 78
19 96 39 47 87 89 13
un pilonnage 29
boss
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as toujours comme ça
tous
je ne peux pas trop vous d'automne
studio sinon taurine wakata me botte
ça veut dire quoi bon s'en donne un
petit peu c'est à dire
mais chez nous ça le plaisantin
quand on perd vous êtes ici depuis
combien de temps dans sept ans à peu
près vous faites votre métier vous
posséderez que ça va bien dans un sens
aussi bon boulot une bouteille la
famille bongo sens là j'ai un petit
problème de logement fois dans le métro
il ya des gens qui vous l'aura qui vous
fixe ça m'arrive de dérangement les
puits de tourner ma feuille enfin
jusqu'au mans et pio
des franches et avec mon fils ne
s'impose pas tomber une à trois ans est
mignonne un petit peu turbulents enfin
les gens plus un parti pris contre les
sous sols enfin là on sent qu'il ya une
différence
on se pose des questions là c'est
choquant fin oui petit petit village
comme ça nous restons comme ça ma gueule
ne leur plaît pas il ya matière
je ne viens pas et des fois ça marche
en deux volumes fixes je le vois en lui
disant la raison pour laquelle c'est un
an
enfin de répondre disons que faute de
lille n'est pas conforme
c'est sa façon de regarder des gens bien
c est dans ces idées pour sa pensée
depuis mais moi je sens que vraiment ils
donnent dominé avec son regard la nommer
ce cas il faut s'habituer
ben non
non je ne contrôle dans le métro enfin
j'me keane enfants jeunes rêvent les
plaques
enfin dû s'éviter la gare face et c'est
devenu comme une habitude et saab a fait
le miel sucré la jeunesse ou les mines
et au travail c'est la même chose bon je
voulais déjà dire je gagnais trois
enfants par semaine et ça m'est arrivé
d'aller le monde est à rallonge
enfin mon chef tu me réponds 10 réécoute
qui bossait tu dois seulement c'était
les débuts enfin je m'écrase et quoi
bien disait bon [ __ ] combien biko
ça se comprend
et maintenant bong joon ho chi soir j'ai
des partants à sadc des patrons qui sont
sympas enfin d'aider des portes travail
qui sont chouettes en somalie vérone
lundi que liège un petit malentendu
redonner trois types bousculer un petit
peu en forme
disons c'est niet et aider mon fils cas
l'enfant
j'arrive 10e et compte laisse tomber
c'est des pauvres types
enfin dans l'instant même si ça me
soulage
puis toujours appelé séparé enfin pas
plus tard qu'hier j'ai été interpellé un
nomade ou chez métro contrat chez moi à
part un bal de flics sont venus y en a
un qui me demande ça descend ça lui et
semble qu'ils me demandaient au
président du thé et l'autre qui commença
puis vous savez aussi pour les gens qui
pensent qu'ils victime lola d'enfin
quiches et par une roquette qui se
demande ce que c'est un mot l'ordre si
ce type là enfin tu avais et puis
j'avais des fois je ne mange ni tient
tout ce qu'ils le font exprès pour
vraiment nous ridiculiser mois et on
parle de tout ça dans le quartier
ah oui on en parle de tout cela on le
touche moi pas content
je peux me défendre si vous avez
d'autres y sont timides
enfin qui sont dépaysés 600 des
problèmes de boulot en fait qu'ils ont
des problèmes de la famille en algérie
bengtsson on savait qu'ils vont boire on
est là on essaie par tous les moyens de
les consoler un petit peu que le deal
écoute va pas plus loin
sa vie n'a rien et puis on n'est pas
chez nous j'aimerais savoir
il se branche sur la boisson
[Musique]
je
et
[Musique]
à
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne veux pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon là bien
guerre
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chirac
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on
ah ah
m
là
eh oui
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
tous
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
m
oh
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l arrivée
voilà
hélas
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jdo
cinéma
[Musique]
high tech
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]